i
[Música]
crítica situación en india por cuenta de
la pandemia varios países incluido eeuu
anunciaron ayudas para paliar la crisis
sanitaria que ya deja más de 195 mil
muertos y más de 350 mil nuevos casos
diarios en los últimos cinco días la
variante conocida como de doble mutación
estaría detrás del auge de contagios
estadounidenses vacunados contra el
hobbit 19 podrán viajar este verano a
los países de la unión europea según la
presidenta de la comisión úrsula von der
layen sin embargo no ofreció una fecha
exacta y apuntó que la última palabra
siempre la tomarán los países de manera
individual
no maduran la gran ganadora de la
edición 93 de los oscar los premios de
la academia se celebraron en una
estación de tren para permitir el
distanciamiento social una ceremonia que
reunió a las estrellas de hollywood por
primera vez en más de un año tenemos
reporte desde los ángeles
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 cerro blanco como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en india país que sufre fuertemente los
estragos que deja la pandemia el oxígeno
vital para el tratamiento de los
enfermos con jóvenes 19 escasea por lo
que una docena de países incluido eeuu
han ofrecido el envío de suministros
médicos la variante india del
coronavirus sería una de las causas del
estallido de esta nueva ola de la
pandemia el país se batió por quinta
jornada consecutiva el récord mundial de
contagios diarios veamos a continuación
lo que la comunidad científica india va
conociendo sobre esta nueva variante
responsable en parte del rebrote del cob
y 19 en india y localizada ya en
distintos países
la variante be 1 617 conocida como
variante india preocupa porque desde que
se detectó por primera vez en octubre en
el centro de india se propagó
rápidamente por todo el planeta
es la marca de la segunda ola las nuevas
mutaciones entran en juego y el número
de casos aumenta enormemente porque
también se ve afectada a la población
más jóvenes incluidos los niños es lo
que constatamos en este momento
y la variante que se expande en este
momento se califica de doble mutación lo
que significa que contiene dos
mutaciones observadas en otras variantes
mutaciones que convierten el virus en
más contagioso y potencialmente más
resistente a las vacunas desarrolladas
hasta ahora pero no necesariamente más
letal en el momento no tenemos razones
para inquietar nos excesivamente
básicamente porque en proporción al
número de casos no observamos un
incremento en la mortalidad ni síntomas
más graves en los pacientes el número de
a sintomáticos es el mismo que antes
según los científicos el crecimiento
exponencial del número de casos diarios
en índia se explica sobre todo por el
relajamiento de las medidas de
protección individual y por los eventos
multitudinarios de estas últimas semanas
los turistas estadounidenses vacunados
contra el kobe 19 podrán viajar este
verano a los países de la unión europea
así lo anunció la presidenta de la
comisión úrsula von der layen en una
entrevista concedida al diario the new
york times
sin embargo bonder layana no ofreció una
fecha exacta o más detalles sobre esta
apertura del turismo estadounidense de
personas totalmente vacunadas desde
bruselas nuestra corresponsal esther
herrera con los detalles
del ritmo de vacunación en eeuu también
podría beneficiar a los viajeros
provenientes de este país así lo ha
asegurado la presidenta de la comisión
europea
ursula von der leyen una entrevista que
ha asegurado que las personas vacunadas
de eeuu probablemente podrán entrar sin
restricciones en la unión europea
muy pronto actualmente las vacunas que
se administran en eeuu las de facer
hansen y modernas son las mismas
aceptadas también por la agencia europea
del medicamento por ello según ofender
legend no tendría que haber ningún
problema ya que tanto las autoridades
estables como las europeas administran
el mismo tipo de vacuna aún no hay una
fecha exacta de cuando ello podría
ocurrir pero sí que se cree que podría
ser pronto probablemente en verano
cuando también estará ya el certificado
digital europeo de momento la comisión
europea ya ha avanzado que está
preparando una propuesta para abrir las
fronteras a los países que
epidemiológicamente se encuentran mejor
entre ellos ahora mismo está eeuu eso sí
la última palabra lo tendrá en los
estados miembros porque son los que
tienen las
para decidir si abre las fronteras y
decidir en última instancia si las
personas vacunadas pueden entrar en su
país sin pcr y sin pasar por una
cuarentena
y en colombia la pandemia tampoco da
tregua
bogotá foco principal de la crisis
sanitaria declaró este domingo la alerta
roja general al sobrepasar el 91 por
ciento de ocupación de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos una situación
similar a la vivida en medellín la
segunda ciudad del país tan sólo ayer se
registraron 465 decesos la cifra más
alta desde que comenzó la pandemia en
colombia rodrigo se da no con los
detalles
alerta roja epidemiológica en bogotá en
una colombia que inmersa en la tercera
ola vive su peor momento de la pandemia
el pasado jueves el ministerio de salud
del país confirmó que se habían superado
los 70 mil fallecidos por kobe 19 y
desde entonces se han marcado récords
diarios de fallecidos alcanzando los 465
este pasado domingo 105 mil 614 casos
están activos en la actualidad con estos
datos en la mano y el aumento de la
ocupación uncía hasta el 91 por ciento
en la capital la alcaldesa de bogotá
claudia lópez decretó el domingo por la
tarde la alerta roja epidemiológica
bogotá todas que en este momento no son
los sistemas hospitalarios sino toda
bogotá esta alerta roja porque tenemos
alta ocupación ya 91% ocupación poca
capacidad digamos de ampliación y además
muy alta transmisión del virus las
nuevas medidas incluyen la suspensión
por dos semanas del retorno a la
presencialidad en colegios y jardines
infantiles toques de queda desde las 8
de la noche y cierre de establecimientos
esenciales y no esenciales desde las 7
de la noche
además habrá ley seca pico y cédula y
confinamiento estricto de jueves a media
hasta las 4 de la mañana del lunes estas
medidas se unen a las decretadas
anteriormente en medellín la segunda
ciudad del país en donde el ejército de
la policía patrullan las calles para
hacer cumplir el toque de queda vamos a
estar en los barrios haciendo un control
de alguna manera pedagógico frente a la
población civil recordándoles en estos
momentos la situación del cob y no solo
a nivel nacional sino a nivel mundial en
este tercer pico
la idea es interactuar con estas
personas que están de alguna manera
incumpliendo este decreto todas estas
medidas se dan antes de una convocatoria
de paro nacional para este próximo
miércoles 28 en respuesta a una nueva
reforma tributaria del gobierno de iván
duque
este lunes 26 de abril ucrania conmemora
el 35 aniversario del desastre nuclear
de chernobil el peor de la historia una
explosión en un reactor en la planta de
energía nuclear contaminó partes de
ucrania y la vecina belarús más de
100.000 personas fueron evacuadas de las
inmediaciones según los expertos el área
alrededor de la planta no será habitable
durante al menos 20 mil años nos
acompaña martín baña historiador y
docente de historia de rusia en la
universidad de buenos aires gracias por
estar con nosotros el profesor 35 años
de esta tragedia nuclear qué
consecuencias e históricas perduran hoy
en día
bueno en principio como bien decías en
la contaminación que ha quedado en el
medio ambiente que va a tener una
extensión de 20.000 años y sobre todo lo
que tiene que ver con la industria
nuclear no esto es de acuerdo a las
cifras que se manejan no solamente los
muertos que hubo en ese momento que
fueron reconocidos oficialmente como 31
sino entre las cifras más este que
tenemos hoy más más actuales hablan de
entre 2 mil y 9 mil personas con con
cáncer e incluso a greenpeace se está
dando este cifras que llegan a 200 mil
personas que murieron de cáncer y que se
estiman en 100.000 más no y lo que
tenemos en el medio ambiente en la zona
de exclusión
de charleville que son prácticamente
treinta y treinta kilómetros a la
redonda que están inhabitables no sí
ahora profesor algunos adultos mayores
han regresado a sus hogares empleos
cercanos a chernóbil argumentando que lo
único que querían era morir en su casa
pero realmente se puede regresar
bueno efectivamente hay gente que se
resistió a irse hay incluso indicios de
vida natural que está emergiendo sin
embargo eso es una zona que sigue
estando esté contaminada a pesar de que
incluso se organizan de tours de turismo
para visitar la zona y lo recomendable o
lo que recomiendan los expertos es no
estar en la zona porque sigue siendo
todavía muy peligroso claro ahora por
último porque la tragedia de chernóbil
aceleró la desintegración de la unión
soviética bueno en verdad las reformas
se venían dando desde antes este ya con
el secretario general andrópov iniciará
una serie de reformas en la unión
soviética en todo caso lo que hizo este
accidente fue acelerar ese proceso
se reforzó con la llegada de mijail
gorbachov al secretariado general en lo
que se conoce como perestroika y glass
que apunto un proceso de reforma de la
unión soviética en parte por los
problemas que condensó un accidente como
como el de charlaba bill que tenía que
ver sobre todo con cuestiones de
económicas
en respecto a la eficiencia de ese
sistema y que terminó en un objetivo no
deseado al menos en principio que fue la
disolución de la unión soviética
profesor gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros aquí en france 24 que te
gustan 2 feliz resto de día nosotros
continuamos con más información acá en
el estudio un tribunal de moscú
suspendió formalmente toda actividad de
la fundación anticorrupción del líder
opositor alexéi navalni y su red
regional la medida cautelar le habían
pedido los fiscales en espera del fallo
del tribunal sobre si calificar a la
organización del criticó al kremlin y
como extremista esto conllevaría su
prohibición en rusia y significaría
duras penas de prisión para los
colaboradores y seguidores de naval ni
y la gala número 93 de los premios oscar
contó con uno de los grupos más diversos
de ganadores en la historia y la gran
triunfadora de la noche fue nombran de
la directora china que william para
ampliar la información conectamos con
nuestro enviado especial en la ciudad de
los ángeles
anthony welsch y anthony muy buenos días
vimos una gala en prácticamente
presencial las estrellas de hollywood se
reunieron por primera vez en más de un
año 16 de los 23 premios se los llevaron
las películas que se estrenaron en
plataformas de streaming como alomejor
netflix hulu o amazon en un año donde no
existiera la pandemia por la que estamos
pasando sería posible que tantos premios
fueran para cintas que nunca se
proyectaron en las salas
así que está muy buenos días de hecho la
academia siempre se haya mostrado muy
reticente a que las películas que se
habían exhibido exclusivamente a través
de esas plataformas como juliette view o
netflix no pudieran optar a los premios
oscar pero la irrupción de la pandemia
ha ayudado a que esas películas sí que
pudieran optar en esta edición número 93
de los premios oscar pero en esta
ceremonia también se puso de manifiesto
la grave crisis que hay con las salas de
cine en este país hay más de 33 mil
repartidas por todo eeuu y de hecho el
sector ha dicho que a mediados de este
año a aquellas cadenas que han podido
sobrevivir a lo largo de estos meses de
pandemia podrían echar el cierre
definitivo si la cosa no mejora de hecho
el actriz francés mcdormand cuando
recogió la estatuilla a la mejor
película porno matt lamb hizo ese
alegato a ir al cine diciendo que en la
gente fuera a ver esa película en la
pantalla más grande posible pero esa
ceremonia de los premios oscar también
fue marcada
la crisis sanitaria se pusieron en
medidas protocolos sanitarios para
evitar los focos de infección a pesar de
que la organización quería mostrar un
ambiente de completa normalidad se
prohibieron las intervenciones por
videoconferencia y se permitió que la
gente estuviera sin mascarilla durante
la gala eso sirve todos los asistentes
tuvieron que hacerse la prueba de el
coronavirus antes de entrar al recinto
ahora anthony vimos que claudia o la
directora china estadounidense se llevó
el oscar a mejor dirección por no más la
cndh pero que otras muestras de
diversidad tuvo la ceremonia
si más allá de los protocolos sanitarios
que tuvo esta ceremonia
la gala estuvo marcada por la diversidad
y por la inclusión de afroamericanos son
mujeres y también extranjeros en esta
ceremonia de los premios oscar
tomatlán que partía como la clara
favorita en todas las quinielas se llevó
tres estatuillas a la mejor película a
la mejor dirección y también a la mejor
actriz de hecho lo es ya o fue la
directora de tomatlán que se llevó esa
estatuilla se convirtió en la primera
mujer asiática en ganar un premio oscar
y en la segunda de toda la historia en
ganar esa estatuilla lo que pone de
manifiesto que en las 93 ediciones de
los premios oscar sólo dos mujeres han
ganado un premio oscar en en esta
categoría
anthony gracias por toda la información
que tengo usted un feliz resto de ella
ya propósito de los oscar los quiero
invitar al especial que ha preparado a
nuestra periodista de cultura yanira
gómez donde analizará y les vamos
los pormenores de esta gala es pero a
las 13 10 de la tarde hora de bogotá
quito lima hasta que el informativo un
día
[Música]